thank you very much so this may be one
of the longest titles to a talk I've
ever given but healthcare is
intrinsically data-driven enterprise but
the way that we use the data and
transform it into compassionate care
brings in all aspects of the human
experience so what I'm going to try and
do today is cover what the looming role
of the IOT in healthcare is and how that
translates into the experience of the
caregiver as well as the physician talk
about sensory overload sensory
disintegration signal annoys management
and then what I call the behavioral
symphony of wellness and the creative
reconstruction of healthcare so just
quick survey how many you've ever worn a
Fitbit or pedometer of any kind okay and
how many have one on today okay maybe
ten percent at most okay I want to come
back to that how many where a
multifunctional sensor or multiple
sensors three okay and how many believe
that wearable sensors will become just a
huge pervasive consumer market maybe
eighty percent and how many of you have
ever emailed your doctor directly cool
we do about 25,000 emails a day between
our members and our patients and how
many of you have given your physician
other types of digital data other than
email Wow about eight okay so the first
thing when I talk about is what i call
the sci-fi generation and the
implications for healthcare so there's
this concept that i like to think of as
a compression of transformational time
so if you look 5,000 years ago five
hundred years ago five years ago the
experience of one generation the next
really didn't change much at all but in
the last fifty years that's really
changed and about five years ago ATT
some of you may have seen it had an ad
and there was about a 15 year old
talking to his twelve-year-old brother
and his 12-yard brother's friend and he
put his hands in his hips and he said
well back in my day when I
your age I had to wait forever to
download a video you guys just take it
for granted and so the technology the
exponential changes in technology are
really having experiential and
transformational changes on a
generational scale that's been
compressed from 20 to 30 years down to
three to five years and so it is kind of
zeitgeist I refer to the current
generation as a sci-fi generation
because it's almost impossible to
imagine how much more acceleration
there's going to be in the human
experience based upon technologic change
and I'm a senior consultant of the
tricorder xprize and I mentor hundreds
of startups and the stuff that's
happening and Stephen was referring to a
lot of them earlier you know nuke
magnetic resonance and intense
spectroscopy analysis the non-invasive
monitoring of human biology is just
exploding and so healthcare is really at
the vortex of this if you look at all
the changes in digital technology and if
you look at how little we know truly
about how the human body operates we are
health care is really at the center of
the vortex in more ways than one so the
doctors brain is pretty constrained so I
was at a policy committee meeting in
Washington two years ago and these were
like the smartest guys in healthcare and
we had a patient advocate in the room
the patient said you know my she was
complaining my doctor didn't even know
that my statin in my antibiotic
interacted and I panicked and went to my
Start phone and smartphone start
searching because I didn't know which I
and about her react would wish dad and
then I looked up and the entire room of
top-notch doctors in the world were
doing the exact same thing because none
of us knew which statin interacted with
an appt with which antibiotic and so
we're way past the fact that the network
is your brain doctor so we're really
well well into an era of sensory
overload and sensory data disintegration
so the information overload is critical
wearable sensor data and health IOT is
rising exponentially
converting these streams of disparate
data types into actionable information
aka clinical decision support remains
very primitive very primitive so the
impact is we have very stressed doctors
and many missed opportunities and
there's actually an article in The Wall
Street Journal just last weekend called
why doctors are sick of their profession
and there is a serious malaise in terms
of what percent of Doc's regret going
into medicine what percent of Doc's
would discourage of children going into
medicine and they listed all the tired
answers you know about lack of
professionalism and time pressure and
yada yada it's all true didn't even talk
about the information overload that is
underpinning a lot of this stress nor
did any of the cures recommend it
address any of what I believe are the
real solutions to the healthcare crisis
a day which is extracting signal from
noise implementing advanced clinical
decision support virtual care and
self-care visualization tools to support
a dialogue where you can communicate
quickly and efficiently with a patient
going to come back to that activating
people in their own health journey and
addressing social determinants of health
so this exponential data tsunami it
continues to accelerate at an
exponential rate ninety percent of all
digital data was created the last two
years ninety percent of all this is my
projection ninety percent of all new
clinical knowledge will be generated in
silico by the year twenty twenty not
through scientifically controlled
studies but through in silico research
and there's emerging data interrogation
techniques that allow us to look at a
correlation and test it in multiple
different environments with different
context and data sets and if we can
reproduce the correlation over and over
again there's a way to infer probability
of causality randomized clinical trials
in traditional clinical research really
going to be reserved for three
situations where the inverses are
ambiguous where the conclusions are so
critical and impactful in health that we
must have a clear viable conclusion and
then for control long-term trials the
omics genomics transcriptomics
proteomics lipidomics react omics
metabolomics expose ohmic social lummix
wearable sensor omics are going to
generate 10 times more data in five
years and 100
or data in 10 years I chair the clinical
electronic health record genomics work
group for the Global Alliance for
genomics and health sponsored out of the
Broad Institute at Harvard but involving
all the genomics consortiums around the
world to try and create the
interoperability allow us to pool the
data to really begin to understand and
there is no such thing as a sufficient
size sample to do genomics research
because there are many many multiples of
more viable genomes than there are
people who have ever walked the face of
the earth so in what is an adequate
sample size not even if we had every
genome ever in existence would it be
large enough to really untangle the
complexity of the human genome
microbiome excited about the ecosystem
in our gut has ten times the number of
bacterial cells in our body a hundred
times many genes as we have in the human
genome and you can tell five years after
a child is born whether they were born
by vaginal delivery or c-section by
their microbiome because they get the
microbiome I'm the mother skin from a
c-section a good friend of mine who I
won't name recently had a baby and he
inoculated c-section he inoculated a
baby with the vaginal the bacterial
microbiome right before birth which
undergoes massive and dramatic changes
in the two weeks before birth and
especially in the last three or four
hours before birth so we're just
beginning to understand this stuff and
then the healthcare Internet of Things
and wearable sensor data is going to
generate massive streams of dynamic data
so I create this term called the
healthcare pleco system because we're
seeing this exponential T across
multiple platforms so Polly Co system is
a contraction a multi-platform ecosystem
so the Internet cloud you beginners
access to data smartphone with video
dial tone and modality steering the
social Oh James Fowler and others have
done amazing research here in his most
recent publication he looked at the
genetics at 1.5 million markers across a
social network and he found to his
surprise he was expected to find
something but he actually found that the
people in your social network are
related to you as closely on average
as your fourth cousin so the way you
choose your social network has a lot to
do with genetics of the people you meet
and a lot of that maps to smell which is
really interesting because that's one of
the most dynamic and volatile aspects of
genetic evolution so we have the
internet and the quantified self come
back to that the expose ohm a pervasive
sensors everywhere look at environmental
influences of health the thousand-dollar
genome so all of this ohmic stuff is
becoming incredibly cheap the
exponential declining cost of sequencing
is super Moore's law and it will be a
couple hundred dollars soon and it will
be foolish frankly not to have your full
genome sequencing available to your
doctor as a standard community practice
very soon electronic health record data
we just have you know billions of
encounter visits on our health records
to data-mine predictive analytics
persuasive technologies BJ Fogg out of
Stanford has done tremendous work in
this space about how to take data and
use it to motivate people it's a real
science around it the role of avatars
artificial intelligence robotics machine
learning heads-up displays 3d printing
augmented reality all of these things
are moving at an exponential speed and
they're all being convergent and
synergistic in the impact in healthcare
the quantified self movement is really
getting a head of steam Larry Smarr many
of you probably know astrophysicists of
Stephen Hawking's labs first person to
set up a supercomputing supercomputer
center in the world helped put together
the team and invented virtual reality
and now is deep into microbio max Mike
Schneider the chair of genetics at
Stanford has an intra personal omics
multi omics profile study I pop I'm a
subject of that so I'm one of the most
quantified people in the world with
terabytes of data about me and I
contribute every three months and
whenever I get sick for microbiomes
6,000 blood asses Jessica Richmond is
doing citizen science with you biome
lynn davies doing curiosity where you
put all of your data into one source
there's there's so much going on in this
space it is mind-blowing and as I say I
do a lot of mentoring of startups how
many startups are really beginning to
think about what it will be like in the
very near future for everyone
so this I'm assuming some of you know
Larry but this is Larry studying at
farmer's wall and what he's showing in
this picture is those are histograms of
basically the species in your microbiome
stirs terabytes of data represented
there and he does it by full sequencing
of what's in your what's in your the
bacteria in your gut and other people
for viruses and fungi and what he has
found is that when you take a series of
antibiotics you create a mass extinction
of the species in your gut the dwarfs
the mass extinctions that have occurred
from various meteors and super volcanoes
in the world and we now know there's
almost 100 diseases that have a very
characteristic signature of your
microbiome so and not to mention the
fact that the microbiome has a very
direct interaction with the genome and
conditions your immune ohm your whole
immunologic response to the world is
conditioned early in life and evolves
and your neuro biome so that and your
connectome in your brain how your brain
is wired so the connections between
these massively complex data sets is
extraordinary so intuitively we all
understand what geometric changes but
it's very hard to wrap our minds around
exponential change so in healthcare the
physicians are already reeling under the
fact that we can now see a patient
emergency room and electronically get
their health record from five ten
different institutions and oh by the way
they don't show the same allergies they
don't show the same problems they don't
show the same medications so we're now
getting more information than they can
possibly handle at a geometric rate so
they get 3 X 5 X 10 X but with Apple
ecosystem overload and multi omics and
wearable sensors there's going to be an
exponential growth in information
available and it is not even imaginable
what's going to happen and Doc's really
can't even I have the hardest time
talking about this with physician groups
because mr. for all of history a doctor
has not put anything into their chart
until they reviewed it so the notion
that there's data streaming into the
chart that's going to be have a backstop
of intelligent filters and escalators is
is just an athame to them I get shouted
another room when I say get over it
because it
coming it has to so where is healthcare
IOT in the Gartner hype cycle this is a
quote for mobile health news mobile
health monitoring is approaching the
bottom of the so-called trough of
disillusionment and we'll need another
five to ten years before reaching his
plateau plateau of productivity and
steady market adoption that's probably
about right and then another one from
international data corporation see
wearable data shipments worldwide will
rise over five fold in the next four
years from 19 million units to 112
million units there's the merging data
sources and news nanobots for detecting
all kinds of things in terms of early
cancer so this is serious research of
startups that are creating nanobots that
that scan for specific DNA sequences
circulating in your blood to know if
you've got a recurrence your breast
cancer your colon count you good program
to say here's what you look for let me
know when you see some because that
means you've got an early recurrence
point-of-care testing using the PCR
polymerase chain reaction testing which
is how we sequence DNA I have a project
that I'm starting now so that when
someone comes into the clinic before
hopefully before they even get there
they can go to a local pharmacy and have
it done there in a couple of minutes for
a couple of bucks and tell them you've
which type of influency have is in h1n1
is an H 2 and 5 is it the dreaded h7n
set n 9 from China the so-called avian
flu with a forty percent mortality rate
or is it rest for syncytial virus virus
and oh by the way and a bio Graham as
well to say yours is or is not resistant
to the drug we recommend for that virus
so we can start triaging people go home
go to the clinic let us know if you give
these symptoms take this drug or not
based upon a five minute five-dollar
tests in a drugstore and oh by the way
the vendor i'm working with who won the
tricorder a nut struck order but the x
prize for sensing based out of boston
was just recently approached to develop
that same technology for the Ebola virus
and so they're they're in production
right now to take these devices to be
able to in a minute to be able to know
if someone has Ebola swab of the throat
put in the device you know autism is
really fascinating because there's over
600 single nucleotide polymorphisms and
they all map to four areas of
neurogenesis
the scaffolding that produces the brain
the brain itself and then the pruning of
the scaffolding and so all of these
mapped that and those of you that
remember your genetics there's a Hawks
like gene that determines limb growth
whether it turns into an arm a wing and
her legs sort of like a super regulator
and it's my hypothesis that there's a
Hawks like gene for autism because all
of these defects map to these four
functions and neurogenesis and neural
pruning and that now that we have 10,000
complete genomics sequences of autism
you start looking for what the causes
and my speculation is the because autism
is such disproportionate
disproportionately represented at
intelligent people in Silicon Valley
that it may well be a tented consequence
of deliberate experimentation in those
elements the brain that accelerate the
rise of intelligence of the human
species and the brain of the human
species have grown faster as an organ
than any other organ in any species ever
so there there's reason to believe that
that there may be down in tended
consequences of this genetic
experimentation skits are finding a
pulling of data the work that I'm trying
to do the Global Alliance for genomics
and health a similar group put together
the genomic data for multiple different
sources and in a matter of months they
tripled what we know about the genomics
of schizophrenia well why does that
matter there are almost 2,000 approved
experiments right now to do genetic
manipulation and it won't be that long
with all these Exponential's it won't be
that long some of the stuff is really
really refractory because of its
complexity but it won't be long before
we start having genetic cures for some
of these really horrible diseases and
then collaboration requires semantic
interoperability which is why I'm
involved with a global initiative for
genetics so with this flood of data
coming in to physicians who are already
like really stressed out and I can't
tell how stressed out they are with with
the flood of data and their inability to
interpret and act on it confidently I've
created five filter sets that we need to
have as a backstop so that we can
the stuff coming to the chart and have
the doctor have some confidence that
there's some intelligent escalation of
what the data says and what's relevant
to that patient so first of all
obviously the value numerical and
graphical values second is the trend and
velocity so for glucose if a diabetic
has a blood sugar of 125 you might say
that's great but if 15 minutes before is
160 that's horrible because they're
headed for a glucose of 40 and brain
damage and this is what we see in our
brittle diabetic so we need the first
derivative the velocity of change as
well third is aggregate values and
there's already evidence and proof point
on this where and there's no single
value that tells you how well hydrated a
person is and you can / dialyze a
patient and leave them and essentially
shocked but it takes multiple parameters
to understand that then there's the
trend of the aggregate value and the
velocity of that and then there's
textual data with NLP natural language
understanding and clinical language
understanding these are all products on
the market today and then finally you
can double all those because we know
that not in not any two individuals are
the same my wife and my daughter both
have a normal body temperature to 97
degrees when they are 98.6 they know
they have a fever they go to the
emergency room they say I've got a fever
no you don't 98.6 well sorry they do but
for most of us 98.6 actually is high at
certain times a day and low at other
times a day because there's a circadian
rhythm that we all follow is unique to
each of us so we need to do is to take
these data streams and create the
personal noah grams so that we actually
can look for outliers based upon our
personal noble grams not homogenized
population-based milligrams so what is
the topology of the sensor network and
the avalanche of data in what stephen
described was the first mile of what he
has calculated as a 3682 connected
devices so from edge the sensor to the
cloud whether aggregated or federated
the various data types the parameters
the principles the way I like to think
of this overall is that we need to know
what data needs to be aggregated to be
useful and what's the lowest point in
that value chain where it's possible to
aggregate and apply analytics 01
the key principles of analytics and big
data is don't drag all the data to the
analytic side but drag the analytics to
the data so my view is let's push the
analytics as far out as we possibly can
so that we can keep the data local we
can all suck it back up if we find
something else but not to try and put
everything everything everything into a
single database and do the analytics
there when when you can already
eliminate a lot of noise lower down the
food chain and then with the data
multiple data types and the parameters
you need to sense normalized transform
aggregate store or compute analyze
escalate compressed archive and purge
all of these functions need to be
managed in a topology that makes sense
so you know when and where you're doing
what so there are three principles that
I use the accordion model of learning
where you think you understand what's
what's noise and what signal and you put
the analytics locally and you just store
the noise and until there might be a
further use but at some point in time
with new technology or new understanding
you open the accordion up again and you
say wow look at these new things who
need to be built or thurs floor and then
you close it back down with those new
fit including those new filters and
periodically with all data in
asynchronous mode you're doing this
accordion action of being open to new
knowledge and applying it and then
shutting it back down and just applying
it in a systematic way second one is how
do you distinguish machine-to-machine
escalation versus machine to consumer
consumer can be the doctor or the purse
of their family and then again move the
analyse the data rather than the reverse
so what do we need from sensor device
manufacturers so the traditional
features our values and dimensions total
cost of ownership reliability volume
pricing durability and multi-user
support the new requirements are and
this is a big one security so apple just
announced yesterday that anybody who
does uses their health kit it's an open
API set for all of their health apps is
no longer allowed to play in the Apple
space if they store the data in the
iCloud anybody want to want to guess why
so it's not just your nude selfies but
it is your clinical data that Apple's
doesn't want in the iCloud transparency
and open source components in
open-source strategy and failure issues
open FDA the FDA is releasing everything
everything everything about all device
manufacturers failure rates and failure
types self-awareness of location failure
self-reporting self-healing full i OT
integration compliance and then what we
need in the future and i'm just going to
skip this in the interest of time but
there's a whole lot of future
requirements we need to meet so how many
of you heard that the FDA shut down the
most popular genetics testing group
23andme because I just happened to be in
boston with Tim O'Reilly at its annual
health food about a month after that
happened and we had one of the founders
of 23andme we had one of the attorneys
the support of the FDA we had one of the
board members Esther Dyson there and we
had this it was a unconference where we
organized so we set up a debate about 23
me and the FDA and what the FDA did is
they based there's the thing thing
called ascertain MIT bias where you
discover a certain correlation a certain
population and then you over generalize
it to a population it wasn't
pre-selected on the base of the first
population there's a lot of ascertain my
bias and the FDA just wanted to say tell
us how you do this so we can understand
the numbers you've given your consumers
and 23andme stalled but what I propose
to the group and that discussion a year
ago is that the FDA is asking the wrong
question the right question is I'm a
doctor and I read the genetics
literature and I see that this patient
has a genotype that means that this drug
is more effective at lower risk than any
other drug in class and yet there's no
fda-approved indication for that drug
for that patient I'm going to give it to
him and I am going to be at risk of
getting sued because the FDA hasn't had
time to review that well that's going to
start happening in mass because the
amount of new information generated
there's an impedance mismatch between
new knowledge and any of the FDA
regulatory processes so what I'm
recommending the FDA is that they turn
from a regulatory agency into one that's
a certification industry that does crowd
sourcing from academics around the world
they certify people to keep up with the
pace of knowledge change and manage it
more effectively ironically Granger
who's one of the biggest suppliers of
farm equipment
if I happen to know them because I grew
up on a farm the feds told them you know
we can't keep up in regulating the
quality of your devices whether all the
ISO standards and so forth so we just
can't do it you have to yourselves but
you still have to use our procedures
that aren't working for us so we have a
lot of work ahead of us to get the
regulatory environments to address the
fact that knowledge is growing
exponentially and all of the review
processes have an intrinsic impedance
mismatch so with all this happening
there's this battle between the utopian
and dystopian it's there's a whole
series of great books so you know the
utopias Peter diamond and abundance and
Byron risa and on how bright the future
is and then you've got the other side of
the coin where you have the second
machine revolution calling out the other
side so Google has already acquired
eight robotics companies and hired Ray
Kurzweil to head up their machine
learning program and they now have a
contract with Foxconn so all these poor
Chinese were pulled out of the farms and
told come work in a sweatshop and you
will be happy are now being told that we
got a robot we don't need you anymore
because health insurance robots is much
less Stephen Schwarzman CEO Blackstone
three billion three trillion I wrote
that run three trillion dollars under
management toward 40 countries at
beginning year in four months and
interviewed all the Prime Minister's
premiers presidents and their number one
concerned with structural unemployment
somebody saw you know when they invented
the wheel when there was the great
revolution when there's a machine
revolution Industrial Revolution
everybody fretted about job loss and we
found new jobs the difference today is
that was arithmetic and geometric change
this is exponential change and the real
risk is is that we're creating systemic
and employment a pace unprecedented in
human history so we need to redefine
work and how we think about that so
finally going to talk about the big
opportunities create what I call the
behavioural symphony of wellness and
creative reconstruction of health care
in response to these exponential
technologies so the first is embrace the
whole person with the behavior symphony
Wallace so if we're just treating a
diabetic oh we're treating a
hypertensive we're missing the point
people spend ninety nine point nine five
percent of their lives out
side of our clinics and hospitals and it
is their micro decisions every day where
health happens and so we need to
consider the whole person the mind the
body soul their alternative and
complementary and integrative medicine
that they may engage in the quantified
self and not the patient so the health
care industrial complex is all about the
patient there's this new movement to
shift to the consumer centric view well
consumers buy stuff we need to look at
the whole person second is community
centric health and wellness we know that
if you do Geo maps of Health and
Dartmouth has a health map that you can
show just extraordinary disparities and
health in very micro communities and it
maps most closely to income and some
people throw their hands up a despairing
say well I can't affect the income
overnight but income is a proxy for all
kinds of other things that can be fixed
so I like to think many of you have
heard of the notion of cognitive excess
and reallocation and and harvesting that
the MIT bread how many have heard the
MIT red balloon project where they
released 10 red balloons all over the
country and they let Team self-organized
with a prize to find the GPS locations
of all 10 balloons and I think I was
like 40 hours but then when the first
team reported that same thing for a
protein folded so I believe there's a
similar to cognitive excess there's
compassionate excess that we should
harvest and there there's a social app
called next door where you manage it at
the hyper local level in your community
we use it I recommend if you don't use
it use it's great and then there's a
global one called impossible comp
started by an Oxford student Lily Cole
so I think this is a much healthier
alternative to play with these
compassionate excess harvest both local
and global initiatives and more
rewarding than playing angry birds ok
opportunity 3 is applying evidence-based
discipline across the entire lifecycle
of aids so there's a lot of evidence
that a lot of the aid that goes to
Africa or South Central LA is basically
a foundation with a hammer and
everything looks like an a on they come
in and there's a book called dead aid as
it was live 8 in Africa
characterizing the sort of sordid
history of institutions coming in to
help and doing more harm than good and
so we need to be able to use
evidence-based tools and data to look
for what are the gaps in the community
what is the appetite for change what is
the capacity for change what are the
tools and the institutions that have
those tools had a sequence and and
synergize those to create evidence-based
execution and finally the fourth one is
privacy versus reciprocal transparency
and truly what Snowden called out is the
fact that we really can't stop this day
I mean we know that the data is going to
end up in the wrong hand so the question
is not how do you prevent the data from
getting there it's question about how do
you provide transparency to who has your
data and what they're doing with it and
I believe that's possible the big
challenge would be how do you protect
the IP when you have that kind of
transparency into the data a lot of
other stuff I'm going to skip this is
just an illustration of the massive
numbers of sources of data for an
individual person that physicians need
to deal with and why we need to have
these filters and decision support
finally six dimensions in the management
of personal data the first dimension is
the arc types of data second to mention
the filters i mentioned third dimension
is the personal noma grams fourth
dimension is the escalations fifth
dimension is avatars as brokers and
avatars going to play a huge role in
terms of brokering our data set with
other people and other institutions and
and I believe that there will be social
avatar interactions that broker these
activities and then the question becomes
who owns your avatar and why do you care
because the more day you feed your
avatar the more value brings to you but
the more you expose yourself to privacy
risks and then the role of pervasive
sensing I see that the markets being
segmented into five tiers the athlete
and the warrior for real-time tuning the
acute illness for wireless and patient
monitoring chronic illness for post
discharged from a hospital and then
restoring illness wellness through
mindfulness and when I asked earlier
about how many ever used a pedometer
10 day was only ten percent digital
nannies don't work so if you're just
counting steps people get tired of it I
got tired of it what we really need to
do is use social networks to bring about
challenges and social support for the
behavioral change but in addition we
need to challenge people to become more
mindful so that you instead of looking
three times a day to how many more steps
you need to take today we want you to
extend it to two days but between looks
and then four days so you begin to
calibrate more mindfully and then
instead of saying how many more steps do
I need today you say oh there's the
elevator where it's the stairway and
become much more mindful about how you
exercise how you eat how you sleep and
how you pay attention and nurture your
social relationships so how will the
digital IOT world shape the future of
human evolution so this is what I call
home America's for the athlete and the
wire and I believe every high school
athlete varsity junior varsity is going
to be wearing accelerometers to look for
injuries and potential concussion in the
very very I mean the helmets already
exists and it's in all the major leagues
it will be at the high school in junior
high school level and then there's an
evolution looks more like some of us
called homo gigas and unfortunately many
of us have back issues as a result and
then thanks to mcdonalds we have homo
fast food or s and then in the evolution
of the flat panel display something went
terribly wrong and then finally
visualization tools to support three
conversations so we need to really have
a very effective visualization tools
that quickly characterize different
options and allow people to drill down
to the data to select their option and I
know I'm running out of time but the
three options are the discussion between
the patient and the professional care
team the patient with their personal
care team their social network that they
trust for that problem and then the
patient with a person that houses that
patient persona because frequently
someone comes in the office they get
this download of data they're
overwhelmed they can't remember it we do
something now called open notes where we
the moment we enter a note in our chart
we sent it to the patient so they have
access to the full medical record note
simultaneous with the rest of the health
care system that they can sit back in
the comfort of their own home and
approaches a person rather than a
patient and the example I like to give
is if you have three options for
treating a 45 year old woman with new
onset of hypertension and diabetes and
one option is maximal benefit maximal
wrist another option is pretty good
benefit but not so much risk a third
option is a pretty good benefit not much
risk and you really don't have to work
that hard to do it and the woman says my
daughter is getting married in three
weeks so give me the easy option for
three weeks and that will cut over to
the high benefit one so I will go ahead
and end on these two slides so what I
believe the evolution we need to seek is
how to use data to create mindfulness
and mindful man and then a quote from
Hubert Humphrey that hangs in health and
human services here in DC that moves me
every time I read it and what he said is
it has been said that the moral test of
government is how that government treats
those who are in the dawn of life the
children those who are in the twilight
of life the elderly and those who are in
the shadows of life the sick the needy
and the handicapped and everything we do
is technologists if we forget the fact
that that the democratization of
technology is a myth it's been exposed
by george packer and numerous writings
we're missing the boat we need to
actively pay attention to how the
benefits of modern technology help
bridge the digital divide and the
growing economic disparities so i don't
know if i have time for any questions
nope all right thank you very much